I'm ja'kayden Brent I play for the Miami
Dolphins I just start being scut I've
been given three options wanted to start
once a bench and wonder could get up out
of here start Friday Night Lights Vince
Remember the Titans and cut Rudy it was
just about one person man it was just
about Rudy in and I know it's all of
that but the number of Titans in Friday
Night Lights was about 13 and I'm a team
player so I had the guy I had to cut
Rudy and then Friday Night Lights start
because I'm from Texas and this one is
in Texas
starting Maddon rephrase that no I'm not
no I'm not I'm starting to call of duty
benching GTA and cutting metal man the
rink is not real man
that's not real I should be one of the
fastest on the game if not the fastest
one time they they did they did that to
my boy Kenan Ellen that's big bro
Robo I don't know how many times all-pro
my boy Jarvis Landry a whole bunch of
guys man I can go down the list I like
come on
[Music]
start Carter three I'm a [ __ ] the
blueprint and i'ma could get rich about
Ron I'm sorry but I mean you talking
about legends here I mean he is a legend
but man obviously I wouldn't want to cut
neither one of them know he I miss Blake
I just had to pick it Richard I'm sorry
man I'm sorry
let's see starting it's a blessing to be
here I'm benching the name the name of
the front of judges is bigger than the
name on the back and cutting defense won
championships even though it's true
difference win championships but I mean
a blessing is a blessing that's all my
god here you know yeah that's gonna be
number one and nobody's bigger than the
team so I mean defense
sorry man I gotta cut you because I play
old friend so hey I'm Jay King grant and
this will start [ __ ] cut